Babies and kids heads
are larger than we think.
In relation to their neck.
They're pretty big.
A newborn head circumference can be
about 15 inches and an adults is 20.
But a newborn neck opening is
usually only about nine inches or so.
So to make a pullover neck opening large
enough, we leave one of the shoulders open
and secure it with buttons.
Make it easier to pull that
pull over over the child's head.
Let's think about how to do
this with any knitting pattern.
Since we're leaving one shoulder open, we
need a bit of an overlap to add buttons
and button holes.
When the sweater's buttoned, the
original seam line will match.
So we're going to add a
few extra rows to the back.
And finish the corresponding
front with buttonholes.
Now if you look closely, I got my lefts
and rights mixed up and I put my opening
on the right side of my sweater.
No big deal.
This is a kid sweater, but I believe it's
traditional for this style to have the
button holes on the left
as the sweater is worn.
Here's my back.
When it came time to scrap off, I just
knit a few rows of garter stitch for the
extension.
Now I followed the pattern all the way up
to that shoulder bind off area and then
finished that back and just added
a few extra rows for the extension.
I chose to use garter stitch
because stockinette rolls.
If you're a stitch pattern doesn't roll,
you could just continue using your stitch
pattern for the extension.
You could also knit or hand
manipulate some ribbing.
Now to prevent bulk.
I really prefer this extension
just to be one layer of knitting.
So a hem doesn't really work well,
especially with heavier yarns.
To create garter stitch over
these small shoulder sections.
Use a garter bar.
You could reform the stitches or use a
hand knitting needle to remove, turn and
rehang the work repeatedly to create
those purl bumps of the garter stitch.
Now one thing to remember, the gauge
of garter stitch is much wider than
stockinette.
So I reduced a few stitches before I
even started creating those garter rows.
In other words, my 16 stitch shoulder
seam was reduced to 13 stitches for the
extension.
When I was knitting the front, I scrapped
off that shoulder four rows or about an
inch before my pattern
instructed me to bind off.
For my pattern, my neck line shaping
was complete at this point, and on that
shoulder that was going to be joined,
I just scrapped off four rows early.
When the front piece was completed, that
neckline was shaped and the other shoulder
was done.
I picked up those stitches with a hand
knitting needle, reduced it down to 13 and
hand knit a few rows in garter stitch.
I worked three button holes
in the center of this section.
In other words, I did not extend
the length of my front shoulder.
I worked my shoulder the same number
of rows that my pattern told me to.
I hand knit my garter stitch.
You could hand manipulate.
I just found it easier.
Now that everything's done.
When I overlap the buttonhole section,
over that extension, I've maintained my
original seam line, the original
neckline open dimension remains the same.
I'll maintain that overlap and carefully
hang both sections when I pick up for my
sleeve.
Now I just need to find a couple of cute
little pink buttons and I'll be all set.